taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking hey taste buddies
welcome to
t-a-s-t-e bus i'm joe derosa i'm sal
volcano here we are today with our first
lightning round episode okay we talked
about this and we have a new format
buster coming at you we're calling these
lightning episodes we're gonna do it
once in a while sometimes we have a
battle that we love or we think is
really good but it might not be
insanely popular things or it might not
be able to sustain a whole episode we
decided to lump those into an episode
together in this one we will be doing
three different battles today you got
tootsie pop versus blowpop you got
sprite versus coke sprite versus coke
which is the headliner the main event
today yeah and then you also got uh
guacamole versus salsa guacamole versus
salsa so maybe these could be whole
episodes i don't know but you're getting
an action packed
filled to the brim taste buds episode
today a triple battle we're gonna put a
clock on so we only have a certain
amount of time to go back and forth on
these things and then you got to move to
the next one
every single win and loss in this
episode counts which means you could be
coming out 3-0 today babe or i could be
coming out two and one or something
would be coming at 0-3 that's correct
yeah well if you were coming out 3-0 i
would be coming out no that's that was a
joke yeah that's what i did yeah which
means he could go three and oh i can go
on three yeah there you go there you go
he's so big uh i think a lot of people
are passionate about guacamole
coke and sprite i don't know about
tootsie blow if they're passionate but i
sure have a favorite they well
look we're gonna get into all of it yeah
i know
just do it because it doesn't it doesn't
go away it's a mental thing it's a
mental illness jesus
truly is an illness no for sure it is
you know what other mental ill mentally
ill thing you do that i didn't know
about you please tell me did i know
about you until we were on a trip
recently
you eat the butts of the bread and the
loaf who eats the butts or the loaf i do
really what do you mean bread is bread
bro never in my life have i eaten a butt
i have only thrown them in the trash
i have never once used a butt for this
isolate that sentence please
um no i uh well but why not it's like a
treat it's like it's curveball it's
different it's a different experience
with you so much crust the ends of the i
also don't call it the butt
i'm just called too much crust it's too
much crust yeah but that's what's fun
about it no embrace it for what's fun
about it
would i like my loaf to be all ends no
but do i like the two ends
yeah do you save the two ends to go
together some people do i you know
you're right you know you're right this
might be the the end of the bread
might be
maybe something to battle with maybe
even on a lightning episode ends of the
bread versus yeah a lot of people do
that like growing up
they just uh they was it usurp mm-hmm
the uh the first one and then you get
all the way to the end and that small
that small top right like a book end
yeah keeps getting and then it's in
there at the end and you have two that's
happened in my household but when i got
older i was like i'm going to lead with
that i'm going to eat it
so you open a fresh loaf
of pepper farm bread you're pulling out
the butt first nah probably not come on
but but i'm not necessarily wait until
just the two are left to have some of
that but
it's a it's a
it's just a terrible piece of bread why
it's it but it has pros and cons to the
other slices of bread it has no roast
by the way is there a certain amount of
is sliced bread standard in the amount
of slices that come in the bread or does
each i know that they they have larger
and smaller loaves but is there like uh
you know is it like 30 slices makes up a
loaf is that something that's
standardized
uh
i no because
here because if you notice like you'll
see loaves of bread that are much
shorter than other ones which is why i
said i know that you're shorter and
longer did you say that yes i didn't
even hear you say that
they call the end the heels
gross i get a heel in my mouth i like
that
gross
wait when did you say that i didn't hear
you say it um just to your face moments
ago
[Laughter]
well because there are shorter shorter
and longer loaves of bread but in those
short and long loaves is it a
standardized slice count
you mean the same amount of slices in
the short and the long no of course not
i just mean saying a shorter loaf has
less slices but always the same amount
yeah like yes like like is a is a
standard i think if you get a pepperidge
farm country white versus a wonder bread
or i think the same lo you're getting
the same amount because they need to
make sure i you know what i've never
eaten a loaf of bread and had an odd
slice of these arnold's brick ovens
there's always even slices
yeah right
so so they do that so it's usually 20 to
24. okay
when i was little my mom went hard with
the arnold's brick oven
it was like it was like a more it was
like a pepperidge farm related like
there was one wonder bread you know like
that [ __ ] could be smooshed into a ball
and it was like cheap and it was like
white bread your typical standard wipe
read through and through but then you
had like
like
brick oven like was like brick oven
arnold's brick like arnold's show me
arnold's brick oven bread uh yeah it's
like their standard like loaf but it was
like it was very like the the slices
were thinner yeah they were thinner and
they were more firm
like like how wonder bread is almost
like super soft where you bite it it
sticks to the roof of your mouth this
was like this like much like more like
firmer i get like much more like
like
i don't look like more precise slices of
bread i get such look at that canned
bread remember canned bread isn't that
so weird i've never heard of that in my
entire life yeah there's bread and a
cake oh you mean you bake it though
no ready like you pop it and no ready to
serve really says it on the can ready to
serve round bread i've never had it but
it's in a can i've never heard of it
i've heard of it i always thought it was
strange
for some reason it's 32 dollars for one
can of it
unless that's a bulk order
oh yeah four no wait how are you it's
awry
you right
oh all day dude i love rye all day whole
wheat and arnold dry is great yeah uh
remember beef steak rye that was like
the mainstream rye bread what that does
not exist
uh i don't think it's around anymore
that exists too crazy beef steak rye all
right
let's start off right now baby this is
lightning we want to go lightning these
sticks are all up in your grill right
now babe i haven't seen it so popular in
years in the uh in the store they do
that soft rye
levees is great
right
i love rye bread it's my favorite oh
it's so my favorite sandwich bread why
don't people like rice oh second is
country white though a country white is
like no joke dude i'm going to give you
a baby
in jail
yeah pb j in a country white is nice
yeah forget it all right today we're
going to start off what do you want to
start baby pick your poison well we know
our headline we know what our headliner
is uh so let's start with the other
what i would say as you would say the
powerhouse duo in this is yeah blow pop
versus tootsie
let's get ready
let's get right to it all right
i
am taking
guess
tootsie pop all right tootsie pop
i
therefore am taking
blow pop by default okay what does that
mean
because you're taking tootsie pop so i'm
taking i'm not taking it by default no
is everything all right yeah pimp you
know a little more business over there
right now
it's like a chevy chase routine over
here
all right uh no not by the fob just
saying yeah so of course that means i'm
um blow pop we're gonna start let's
start the clock we're going to lightning
ground tootsie pop blow pop boom
what are the parameters of the lightning
round we have like we argue we have
seven minutes total no eight minutes
eight minutes total get get either side
in yeah either side you're wasting yeah
right now first of all we're not going
to show results to the very end i
understand that we're not showing
results to the very end it all comes
together here we go tootsie pop is
better i think tootsie pop is going to
dominate despite the popularity of blow
pops uh the gum in the blow pop which is
called charms blowpop yep by the way
charms the blow pop company has the
charms company the blowpop has the
charms company backing it up right the
tootsie
roll the tootsie pop has the sea company
back
the tootsie roll but what else does
charms make uh they make some candies
that i think what else does tootsie make
besides their little tootsie rolls that
nobody wants i think part of uh
isn't tootsie part of a major uh all
right cute kids come see me in austin
september 24th at the paramount theater
that's for the moon tower comedy
festival uh i will be headlining there
and then the next day september 25th i
will be in denver at the bellco theater
with david spade and frank caliendo for
charity uh all ticket to
salvocanocomedy.com and then i'm on tour
with the guys this tour has started it's
an arena tour i'll tell you the first
weekend uh glendale arizona san diego
california and sacramento california
those are the first big dates but all
dates are up and they're at the
tenderloins.com
tour
i'm sure charms has its hand and some
other things let's see let's see what it
is
tootsie
is
uh
uh just go to just go to the wikipedia
page
tootsie make
oh boy
okay tootsie is a 1982 american
they make tootsie rolls oh they're their
own industry so tootsie isn't even owned
by like mars eminem hershey
tootsie roll industries that makes me
like it even better okay tootsie roll
let me just go whatever it is i think a
c becomes a tootsie roll to me yeah
tootsies back in the 60s when there was
no better candy available
let me see that tootsie roll
that you would pull in a roll one of
these
look at charms get it get it let me see
charm squares charm squares or are the
charms versions of the texture
like all they all they all they have is
just like a sucking candy that's like a
lifesaver and really that's it do you
know how dark times were when a child
would look forward to pulling that
sticky turd out of that plastic
and then it sticks to it like when it
looks like a sticky turd yes is
everybody over that fact yes i mean the
country a long time ago got over the
fact that it looks like a sticky turtle
this day if i had to play a [ __ ] prank
on somebody tootsie roll is what i'm
buying first i mean it looks like a
rabbit turd it's not a human turd
i love tootsie you know what i love
about tootsie they might have other
flavors but it's just like all you need
is like they oh
how they flex it's like you want a
bite-sized tootsie roll a medium tootsie
roll a big tootsie roll like all they
need is just like they just play with
size and i feel like i'm just getting
one i have tootsie rolls and tootsie
pops often
often
define
not the pop the pop i believe cause i'll
have a tootsie pop often they got them
in banks still and stuff like that
when are you having a tootsie roll be
honest yeah where i think if someone has
a bowl of candy
if someone has a ball you just said i
eat tootsie rolls often i want you to
tell them guys have been here where are
you getting them often i probably had a
twitchy roll
a couple weeks ago on my parents from
where
they buy a bag of the super buy a bag
okay your parents have a bag in the
house at all times i'll be honest i
don't buy tootsie rolls at the register
that's what i'm asking no i don't buy
this i buy them by the bag though yeah
and you know where they are
you know where they are at the register
bottom shelf no with the honey bites and
the mary janes and all the other [ __ ]
candies on that box
is not a [ __ ] candy man okay it's also
stayed the course of time it really is
in the same wax wrapper they also didn't
change the taste of it it tastes like i
taste tasted tootsie rolls when i was
little probably made when you were
little they've just been sitting there
forever but a lot of products just we
talk about this often they they waver in
quality and taste over time the taste
profile changes tootsie pop tastes like
it always has i digress let's talk
first okay let's talk the gum inside of
charms blow pop is a no-frills
unidentifier you are you are a hundred
percent wrong you are 100 wrong it is up
there with like trading card bubble gum
it's got its own taste it's delicious it
tastes like bubble gum flavor it's up
there he said the words it's up there
with trading yeah
specialization
card bubble gum is the worst bubble gum
no that's not true remember how special
that was when you were a kid you got a
pack of baseball cards popping that gum
in your mouth was a special event
because it tasted like its own thing i i
get that but it but it's good enough for
the taste palette of a four-year-old a
two-year-old or a six-year-old you put
that in your mouth
you get it to a point where it's soft
10 seconds after trading come or a
trading com
i said trade income
10 seconds after trading gum cards
uh trading card gum that's what i was
trying to say ten seconds that the
trading card gum is eaten it has no
flavor the same exact as it puts you up
as a blow pop you wait to get to the
middle of a blow pop all that time and
then you get there and it is you rip it
off the you gotta bite clamp down to the
high heavens you gotta rip it off the
stick some of it stays on there and then
god forbid you have a filling a cavity
or something that deep you chew it and
then it finally softens and then you get
the burst of flavor for 20 seconds and
then that thing is a wad of chewy
tasteless favorite flavorless and it
starts to get more rubbery when when you
the more you chew
uh a
blowpop gum it starts to like get like
squeaky like all the uh the sugar has
come out of it it's just it's really
like you bite it and almost get i almost
get that feeling sometimes that i get
like on on nails on a chalkboard it's
like it's like i'm just like oh this
doesn't taste good it gets tougher
oh god you're reaching man i'm not
reaching
no i'm making my blow pop argument right
now i'm making my blowpoc argument the
flavors of blowpock pop demolish
they demolish the flavors of tootsie
roll you get a blue raspberry blow pop
forget it tootsie roll has one good
flavor wrong cherry wrong that's it no
that's it i disagree and i was going to
say this tootsie pop you like the grape
one has basic flavors they've stayed the
same and every one of them except maybe
ch i get chocolate is disgusting
chocolate is my least favorite and you
think the grape one is just cherry
orange grape troll you think the
grapefruit is great and then i think
they have a rise you think the grape
ones have a raspberry you think the
grape one is good you think grape goes
with chocolate i think it's terrific
you're nuts charms you got your standard
cherry the the basic one and then you
have a grape i think those two are good
i don't like the strawberry i think it's
too sweet the blueberries like the apple
the sour apple charms blow pop is
amongst one of the most disgusting
candies that's one bad food new enough
not
lime
i want to see more apples i want to see
new tootsie roll flavors over the years
or tootsie pop favorites it says six
flavors versus 12 flavors okay so we got
12 flavors of the blow pop which since
when is that a bad thing
yeah about blow pop flavors the only one
good blow pop flavors are original and
grape that's not true blue rash is my
favorite blue raspberry is too much man
it's not too much
it is the most popular of the blow pops
who said that it's the one you see
everywhere when you see a ball a bullet
guarantee you it's not in the top three
most popular i guarantee you no way most
popular
uh blowpop flavors please you want to
make a wager on this
you think blue
is one of the is the most sold blow pop
not original and then grape and then
probably sour apple look at what look at
the word that's bolded right there look
pimp come on
most popular blue razz i just called it
kiwi berry terrible kiwi very blessed i
don't know say you're saying i'm really
wrong say i was wrong
and the brand's most popular blue razz
say joe i was wrong
i don't
i don't know about that
you don't know about it it says it right
there what do you mean you don't know
about it
i don't know about that
what
[ __ ] here it is chocolate cherry grape
orange raspberry for tootsie wait but go
back to
what do you what do you not know
we asked the question and the brand's
most popular blue razz because it's the
most popular but it's like a weird
truncated sentence whenever he clicks on
these paragraphs sometimes it combines
like multiple sentences
no you know you know what i mean it says
the brand's most popular blue red just
put in most parts
at san diego
[Applause]
crunch
you can't do this you can't blow past
the clock it's okay this is no good man
i have so much more i don't care you
wanted to do this here we are okay
versus always
you have to follow the rules blue rise
sucks
i go this is so dumb
this is dumb
i i i you know what these were your
rules that you made up i got flustered
though because i didn't realize that
when i was trying to get out you had to
shut the [ __ ] up
when you had to not talk for six minutes
straight and mainly and waste all your
time shooting your mouth up what i hope
you learned i realized was putting the
clock on it actually made me
discombobulated really i was like my
brain was going faster than my mouth
something completely simple overwhelmed
you i've never seen that with you before
um i think tootsie pop's going to win
all right
here we go tootsie pop blow past this
clock i think a tootsie pop is more
iconic than a than a blow pop stop
talking about it that's not how
lightning round works
ready pimp guac versus salsa go
guacamole right here baby this gummy
took salsa
he goes i'll take salsa will you take it
take it and shove it right up your ass
because it is the loser in this round
you're going against guacamole dude the
good fats of the avocado the tomate
chopped up tomato chopped up onion
chopped up cilantro a little bit of lime
juice some chopped up jalapenos some
salt some pepper dude you that is a meal
brother that is a meal a hearty salsa
can be a meal it's also it's also diced
up veggies and and etc it's nice to
veggies and it sits in a jar now it's
like can stay good forever so you know
it's got like god knows what in it it's
just salt
how come it stays for sure first of all
guacamole
just the word guac
like guac it's one of the most
unappealing sounding words ever it's
indicative of
the uh of the guac itself
it just sounds like a disease oh do you
ever
guacamole with mango in it dude it's
do you have
unreal dude guac and guacamole it just
sounds like you have like you have to go
you have to go to the uh
what's the name of the skin doctor
you're wasting a lot of pressure
you always have a little guacamole
why kind of mighty i'm serious is this a
gallagher routine
i will crush your guacamole right in
front of you i'm telling you this right
now you're wasting a lot of precious
time on the wrong avocados are i think
over hyped i mean you put out some guac
let's be honest you put out some guac
for 15 minutes you look down the thing
looks like a pile of [ __ ] no no no
that's i don't know why you put fresh
lime juice on it so it doesn't it helps
it for a little bit no it stays it stays
good
you make a nice guac you put all that
effort in you're muddling the avocado
you're squeezing in all your juices you
put it in the fridge one day later you
pull it out it looks like it was in the
fridge for six months that's true and i
and and and you know
you know what i've seen you do what i've
seen people do and i can't do when you
push the brown guac out of the way
to
to to get to the to get to the green
in this very building
eat
brown guac
that was left over from a taco meal you
had the day before no you didn't yes i
did and pimped it too
and you said this is good guac and you
gave it to pimp and you both hate it
you are so full of it if i if pimp so
chose to eat the brown guac that's fine
let me tell you something guac is more
brown than green
honey
i'm home
which is what my packages sing when they
come to me with additional discounts
provided by honey i shop online i click
that honey button that comes when you
install the plugin to your browser i did
i have it coupons when i check out of
things i get discounts honey finds them
all for me in a matter of seconds and
even reminds me to click the button when
i forget to do it i love honey i use it
all the time i have it on my laptop as a
plugin i have it on my phone as an app
uh it's it's the best thing you don't
ever want to get to that checkout you
don't ever want to get to your shopping
cart and check out and it says enter
promo code here and then you got nothing
yeah honey checks every place for you
and puts in any single applicable code
which is the coolest idea i have heard
in a long long time by the way folks
they're offering you deals on top of
deal i've been on websites where they're
already saying use this at checkout and
then honey can toss maybe one or two
extra things anything clothes gadgets
pizza tech i mean you know you could
save anything it has 17 million members
that have saved them over two billion
dollars in savings look if you don't
already have honey this is easy there's
no cost to get it i just and it only
saves you i just got a blu-ray of a
movie called microwave massacre
the arrow edition uh anniversary edition
of microwave massacre an exploitation
film
horror picture from the early 80s that
starred the voice of frosty the snowman
for our lives no
no he was the he was the claymation one
okay i'm in the cartoon what does that
have to do with honey then i'm telling
you okay please that's the last thing i
ordered yeah and honey helped you with
it can you help me out all right if you
don't already
thank you that was and that was like two
minutes in there that honey will
appreciate it if you don't already have
honey you could be straight up missing
out on free savings like joe it's
literally free and installs in a few
seconds by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting taste
buds
get honey for free at joinhoney.com
taste buds nice and easy joinhoney.com
taste buds
uh we want to talk to you about cuts now
cuts is a clothing uh company cuts that
have taken classic men's fashion staples
like the plain tee and refined it
combining premium quality with
minimalistic aesthetic they have shirts
polos hoodies crew sweatshirts uh made
for the man who works hard plays hard
never settles for less all in the sports
business it's built for performance in
the boardroom the bar the thing about
cuts i like you can dress them up you
can dress them down you wear them to the
gym you can wear them to the office it's
kind of that's kind of really cool
because it's extremely versatile you
take a plain tee and you you batman it
up a little bit there's nothing better
than the basics that's what you build a
whole wardrobe off of babe i hear you i
hear you i have what's called a uh
i forget the term but it would be the
term for pee-wee herman's wardrobe
it's a lot of the sames so you don't
have to think too much about what you're
sure sure i like about cuts it can give
you some real good staples you can get
multiple steve jobs right didn't he wear
the same outfit at all times so we
didn't have to think about it something
like that that's how i go on the road i
get i get a black
v-neck
for every night of the week and i just
go and i don't think about it there you
go and that's what cuts is going to help
you do what you're working cuts is
premium with a purpose each piece of
clothing is designed with custom
engineered fabric expertly graded for a
perfect fit which i love too they're
really quality t-shirts arming you for
every challenge and opportunity it's not
just a lifestyle it's not just clothing
it's office leisure apparel for the
sport of business and that is
that is basically where we're headed
that's a very
that's a i'm going to say something that
slogan is flame the grim reaper is
coming for the dungaree
the athleisure is not just for the gym
anymore we
they've
can
the code yeah we dress at leisure up now
we stay comfort every day get 15 off
your first order
by going to cutsclothing.com
taste buds that's cutsclothing.com
slash taste buds you're gonna get 15 off
the only shirt worth wearing
guac starts off green but turns brown
right away and then that's it it's
called a decent food that's not loaded
with a bunch of preservatives salsa is
is
you you talk about the high-end food for
the people the uppity people and the
working man's food yeah salsa is a
working man's food i know salsa came
from the people salsa
when i'm feeling fancy i say sir
gossand
wheel that card up to my table and i
want to watch you make it right in front
of me i mean it's an experience i could
eat a jar of salsa in one sitting you
say you talk about mangoes you have a
mango in in your guac what about mango
in your salsa that's insane mango salsa
is a thing i buy it all the time all
right it's got heat it's got sweet it's
got texture it's got crunch
it's got
everything guacamole on nachos kicks it
up 10 notches
salsa on nachos ruins the nachos
literally ruins it but a chip a chip
with salsa chip with guac i take chips
and salad salsa on a taco ruins the taco
guaca taco kicks it up if i my first
scoop into salsa with a chip i put in my
mouth i'm like oh my god i'm going to go
through this bed like get this bag away
from me guac is good and stuff but it's
like you take it you eat it and you have
a few of it but i'm not going to go
through the whole bag of chips with guac
i'm just not it's awesome it's just i
don't know
salsa is the bottom rung of dipping
condiments
that's not true are you insane walk up
here most people don't know so up here
french onion dip up here spinach dip up
here
salsa yeah you know what you know what
sauce is cool who sauce is this the
whole industry you give it
salsa is what they give you sauce is
what they give you salsa is so low rent
they give it to you for free at any
mexican restaurant before you eat your
block is so upbeat they have to
overcharge you for it well no that you
you pay for what you're eating but salsa
they go here you just have it we
wouldn't even dare it's made of
vegetables it's made by the people it's
useful it's affordable it's worldwide i
would actually
count your argument and i would say
salsa is probably the most popular and
used condiment over every
is it really a comment whatever you
called it you over every one of those
dipping sauces i only know that because
george castaneda said on seinfeld no
because people like to say salsa yeah
but he says that he goes salsa is the
most popular condiment in the in the
world why don't why isn't it on every
table he says that okay do you know why
no i'm saying that's where you got
yourself
where are we at pip
lightning round timer oh five man okay
we got a little time here left what time
when was oh good you can read this does
avocado avocado has no taste it is true
i mean everything else in there is what
you're tasting the avocado doesn't have
much of a taste they need to be seasoned
uh
to within an inch of their worthless
lives to actually have any kind of
flavor you could have no taste buds and
still not lose the sensation of enjoying
a slice of the green pulp on crisp bread
10 reasons that the disgusting horrors
that are avocados need to be called
please click for metro dot co dot uk oh
i can't see that
uh they're bland they're bland they're
slimy they're slimy they're everywhere
it's not really a
good one
they're a nightmare to prepare true i
mean the ripeness is never right
they ruin perfectly nice food they're
overrated i mean some of this stuff i
agree with people who don't like
avocados are judged
it's hard to spell okay
i don't know dude i just think come on i
just think guac is super overrated i
think they up charge you for it funny i
want you to eat guac today when you had
a choice between guac and salsa i didn't
have a choice i saw you
this is how we came up with this i
didn't have a salsa choice i had to go
pack it to guac i didn't eat yet i used
it as a healthy on-the-go snack if i had
if i had salsa i would have chose the
salsa just because i ate guac doesn't
mean that you can use that against me
but for you to disparage it like this
when i watched you wolf it down i mean
it was a clear disc three scoops clear
every part of it that's from going up
with no money you know
i i i don't know how you could salsa is
glorified ketchup no not guacamole is a
no i refuse to accept it it's a cuisine
it's a cuisine it's glorified hot sauce
salsa
and it's i can't think of one thing i
like to put salsa on aside from again
when i get to the mexican restaurant i
am so hungry i can't wait to tell you
love and i just get to eat the free
chips and sauces don't you love that
they give it to you for free you're
saying that like it's a bad thing oh
it's so low on the on it's so low on the
ladder that they give it to you for free
when you get there i choose to see that
as a plus i love my freestyle so you
think every mexican restaurant you go to
is so
in the uh in the black
financially they're they could just
afford to give this [ __ ] away you don't
think it's because it's a dime a dozen
no i think it's because they're up
charging on the guac and making that and
giving the salsa away for free guac's
been carrying your salsa ass for a long
time and it'll continue to do so nobody
says let's go to the restaurant they
have great salsa they say let's go to
the restaurant they have great guacamole
it has been said and that's our time
it's the beauty of the lightning
the guac has come on strong in the last
10 20 years salsa has been day one don't
ruin it the beauty of the lightning it's
part that's the beauty of it don't worry
guac all right yeah i want brown
here comes the king the king battle
today
versus sprite and guess what team genius
is on
i think the coke is in our blood i think
it's coke is americana i think coke is
the holidays i think coca-cola classic
is the 50s i think coke is the number
one
soda in the world but just like we did
um we did something else and it got
taken out like mcdonald's got taken down
by wendy's and things like that i think
sprite is the dark beautiful crystal
horse
that is going to take out coke i think
coke a cola classic has been around
forever people get it there's a reason
why it's been around we didn't put coke
against pepsi because we thought that
coke would win against pepsi and so
instead even though i think pepsi i
might even like sometimes better than
coke 129 years old
pimp i want you to show me the numbers
what does coke sell in a year
well okay but
let's all right
coke soda soup this is gonna be a tough
one for me but i'm hoping that every all
your element oh my god
it's just in the u.s just in the u.s
that's outrageous
33 billion no no no but that's the
coca-cola company my friend sprite is
included in that sprite is a coca-cola
product it should be said we were going
to do coker's pepsi and we thought that
they were too close and i thought that i
needed a zag to go with the zig so i'm
i'm shouting out i'm reaching out to all
my lemon lime
lemon lime
people out there lemon lime people who
love the alternative fish you know when
i drink
an ice cold sprite
i there's a crispness to it the lemon
and lime make me feel like this is a and
it's clear so you don't feel like you're
drinking this syrupy
like redundant
just sprite is the third most consumed
soda in the world coke of course is the
first has been the most popular soda
brand in the us and around the world for
decades and continued its dominance last
year now we're gonna rally i mean you
sprite's gonna rally
do you understand something let me let
me diet coke is number two perspective
for you let me put coke in perspective
for you
bill cosby
was their spokesperson and they survived
that
do you understand why i see this folks
the strength of their brand yeah didn't
bill cosby used to do coke commercials
isn't that why jello isn't that i know
but isn't that why the eddie murphy joke
tell bill i said i have a coke and a
smile and shut the f
yeah yeah you did coke commercials oh
[ __ ] yeah do you understand the strength
of that was 40 years ago i understand
but trust me when i tell you this if
sprite
sprite has nothing to sneeze at it sells
fifth billion dollars right here all
right but my product is colorless lemon
lime flavored soft drink created by the
coca-cola company it was first developed
in west germany what in 1959 as fonte
claire
zetrone phantom clear lemon fonta wait
they're fantastic so it's connected to
fanta that that european soda it was
introduced in the united states i feel
like when i think that uh
well we know that sprite was introduced
as the competitors to seven up but i
think sprite has passed seven up in
popularity i will tell you this as far
as the lemon lime don't drink seven up
anymore they don't talk about it like
they used to seven up was king for a
while as far as the lemon lime soda goes
and yes i am going to talk about your
soda in a complimentary way because i've
got this so locked i'm just going to
coast you know what i mean i mean
there's no way coke is losing
but my point is this i feel those sprite
people out there band together as far as
the lemon lime soda goes i i will go
sprite i i do not like the taste of
seven up anymore it tastes too much like
sugar like just straight sugar to me
uh i do love a sprite it's great but i
mean
you sit down what's more refreshing you
sit down at a burger restaurant you go
to the movies
you you you come on dude
a coca-cola float with ice cream it's
like it's cooked
it tastes like here we have it the
primary taste of coca-cola is thought to
come through vanilla and cinnamon with
trace amounts of essential oil spices
such as nutmeg i don't really taste much
of that in there
maybe but uh
it's caramelized sugar i got and
slightly astringent i got two twelve
packs of soda in my fridge in my
refrigerator right now coke zero then
the re-flavored coke zero which is great
and cherry coke here but when they tried
to do coke too yeah and everybody told
them no yeah we don't want coke too you
stop it right now and then they've made
an apology announcement and said due to
the overwhelming demand
let's just forget about coke too yeah
yeah and they said go back to coca-cola
they blundered coca-cola is not without
error they are not
and like sprite is a
healthier alternative like it's clear
and it has lemon and lime in it it just
feels more vibrant you know that tangy
zingy refreshing so coke just feels like
sometimes like it's just like
ah man like yeah like it just feels like
i just feel like it's like eating away
at
you ever like they drop a tooth in a
coca-cola can and it's gone in like a
week what happens when you drop a tooth
and spray but i don't feel that way well
i gotta tell you feel that way
i also think there's no caffeine in
sprite confirm it's an eye pimp it said
no caffeine no caffeine for all the
people that are okay
right well who the hell raise up raise
up caffeine free it also says coke
changes the hue of your teeth
oh wow yeah what about that oh my people
are still drinking it people know it'll
eat the paint people know it'll eat the
paint off your car they'll still drink
it that's how good it is they use it to
take rust off of bumpers that's how good
it is that people still drink it even
after seeing that i've seen them do that
but you know what i'm saying we've had
enough of standard cola
why are you talking like sprite is some
rogue like
i just think that i mean this is this i
just think that's britney spears
there's a version of coke i guess
there's a version of lemon lime for
everything too
i was like there's shasta
there's there's rc cola there's
[ __ ] there's all these different none of
them can come close dude they actually
have to ask the question when you're in
a restaurant you say all the coke they
go is pepsi okay because they know it's
a travesty no that actually i think was
contractual they have to do it
babe let's blend it up i like my hard
celts but i like a little something
extra in it and that's where visitors
like your antioxidants and your vitamins
i like my vites my antiox in my salts uh
i got busy downstairs i got four
different watermelon based flavors but
they also have pineapple mango black
cherry lime
strawberry kiwi blueberry pomegranate
and so on and so on i'm loving these
watermelon flavors i really love them
they're also launching a lemonade hard
salsa did you know that no they're
getting in the game big time and this is
the only spike seltzer that has the
antioxidants and vitamin c look if
you're going to have a drink if you're
going to indulge if you have a crisp
delicious viz why not have why not have
something healthy along with it yeah i
want to have vitamins antioxidants in
everything i eat i love that they're
doing the blueberry flavors i love that
they're injecting blueberry things
cranberry has injected into many drinks
over the years blueberries time has come
love bloobs i love it i love it
it's as strong as a beer it's five
percent alcohol volume is only 100
calories so they're right in there with
everybody else yeah less than a gram of
sugar which is real cane by the way yep
per can every sip of visi is more
exhilarating and then i think one carb
or less per can or something like that
right so upgrade your hard sell to busy
here's where you're going to go buy it
dot com slash taste buds that's vizzy
hardseltzer.com
tastebuds order some today
must be 21 or older
knock knock
who's there joe hello hello fresh
let's just skip right to something that
i want to talk about with hellofresh is
that with the offer the offer is
gangbusters with the offer they give you
14 free meals which is more than i can
say for a lot of people that advertise
um you know falls busy and hello fresh
here to save your time otherwise you'd
spend it meal planning and going to the
store and chopping stuff up this stuff
comes pre-packaged ready to go it's good
for single folk it's good for families
it's good for people that are trying to
learn how to cook you're getting more
acclimated here's why fall is great too
okay for for you to starting with hello
fresh okay the fall harvest is
officially
on with hello fresh because they're
doing seasonal recipes like pumpkin
cinnamon rolls and friendsgiving ready
sides and all that kind of stuff but my
mom would always say in the summer when
i was growing up it's too hot to cook
let's order out the fall is such a
wonderful time to cook
the the leaves are turning the breeze is
cool the air is fresh you love that foam
it gets a little dark a little earlier
cornucopia of uh yeah and you just it's
a warmth you want to be in cooking a
nice meal
with someone you love or if you're me
desperately alone but it doesn't matter
hello still like cooking that meal
hellofresh is one of the ones that sells
itself it's it's 30 cheaper than going
uh shopping at grocery stores it's it
comes right to your door it's convenient
i mean i love it we love it we use it we
we you know we we'll talk about it all
day long i've said before in the past
the strongest accolade i could give or
compliment i could give to hellofresh is
i do like to cook and i like to buy
things and make it from scratch and i
still like hello fresh because it
doesn't feel like some cheap shortcut to
a real meal you actually feel like
you're cooking because you are but it's
easy and convenient and you're kind of
learning a little flair in there it's
great uh go to hellofresh.com
tastebuds14
uh tastebuds14 and use the code
tastebuds14 for up to 14 free meals
including free shipping uh that's
tastebuds 1-4 and use code taste buds
1-4 and then use the code as well taste
buds 1-4 for up to 14 free meals uh
hello fresh babe america's number one
meal kit they have they're not allowed
to give you pepsi i understand yeah
first of all it doesn't contain can you
read that because i can't see it it
doesn't contain phosphorus acid which is
known for dissolving your bones by
flushing my calcium simply speaking it
does not why sprite is better than coke
sprite does not contain phosphorus
phosphoric acid and it has no caffeine
that's he's saying that's why it's
better less sugar than original coke but
you're missing my point sal
you're missing my point obviously they
can't serve you something what is your
point tell you it's something else
please tell us
they had they don't say we have pepsi
i'll bring you one of those they don't
say don't worry we have pepsi they say
is pepsi okay
because they realize what you asked for
was champagne and they're bringing you
boone's farm do you understand that's
where that's not what it is that's where
coke stands you ask for something
specific they don't have they have to
let you know what they have is that's
why they say okay they all say at the
same time you think that you you think
that the people that carry pepsi are
like i'm sorry we have boone's farm
levels cold for you
pepsi is terrific you just weren't first
to market
that's all pepsi's a powerhouse pepsi is
uh not great the fight is not coke pepsi
man i don't know what i'm saying
all i'm saying is coca-cola falls under
the standard cola flavor and i'm gonna
place a bet
that
anyone who is and the anti-standard cola
flavor
will rise up and vote for sprite and
that's time sprite over the
this is gonna be
all right so we have the three poles
here right yep
all right let's start with no no that's
the headliner
i'm going to lose that
tootsie blow start to t blow
okay only 9 000 votes on this one well
we're only 20 we like yeah you're right
it's only 20 minutes in okay we're 35.
okay all right let's just go to the
result do we do we need to pick uh but
24 minutes of battling yeah let's just
go to the results
for this one we won't pick a winning
thing it's it's gonna be too long oh no
no we should read some comments bro
35 minutes let's read a couple of
comments that's the whole point
no guys my grandparents always had
tootsie pops at their house i always
hated going to my grandparents house
that's very funny no guys ever asked me
out on a second date because of a
tootsie pop i don't know what that means
she means a [ __ ]
the flavor of gum lasts the same amount
of time the tootsie roll lasts they're
not even worth it
tootsie roll is great
unlike that gross rubber gum i called it
uh
[Music]
and there's the owl can scroll a little
bit pimp
tootsie pops always who in their right
mind can pass up a tootsie roll or a
tootsie roll covered in sweet sugary
goodness i don't even like chocolate and
can't pass up a tootsie pop i agree with
you two more and then we'll move on blow
pops are hard shell can't
blow pop sorry blow pops hard candy
shell and tootsie rolls do not go
together tootsie roll pops are the
devil's spawn of candy and then finally
why would anyone want to spend time
getting through the center of a candy
shell only to discover a tough
disappointing piece of gum eating a blow
pop is like being a mets fan ends in the
poo in disappointing blow pop gum is
staler than joe's love life
so i would go
that was brutal i'd say uh our winner is
the grandparents comment that's very
funny
right yeah i'll take that
i
follow i'm getting a sense here that
people are going tootsie with me though
at follow at k c a k e underscore j a p
l e n 7.
thank you sir i think that was great
hi pimp what are you going on this one
oh
i just felt a shooting pain in my chest
oh i'm taking these things too seriously
oh this is wrong oh it's less than one
percent which means even in five minutes
the tide could change too bad we gotta
move on it's a lightning show
fifty point eight percent blowpop is the
winner to 49.2
humble pie
h-u-m-b-l-e
oh we forgot to do the battle chat did
we do it no
we didn't no so we speak
t-l-e
the battle boys
we're the battle boys and this is taste
buds no all right let's do this
didn't do it no i know jesus we did the
thing at the beginning all right look we
got to remember
h-u-m-b-l-e pie
all right say it like that like
yeah
all right guac versus salsa
click
clicked guac meant to click salsa while
guac is good salsa has the zing to it
that guac i can't get i agree but let me
tell you something right now what if you
win by a vote
that's true guacamole
salsa all the way i can already hear joe
nobody in the history of the world has
ever wanted to eat brown good that's me
wow you guys got to get with it
guacamole at its peak is at its peak way
better than salsa but salsa is harder to
mess up
salsa but don't give me that [ __ ] that's
so chunky it's like eating entire chunks
of fruit veggies give me the stuff that
is heavenly all right you know i like
guacamole but i can't get past the look
of texture it's too close to vomit
guac is extra for a reason
guac is avocado diarrhea wow is squat
gonna lose
oh i hope so
guac all day babe i love both
tootsie pops
that's actually really bad less than one
point
i don't know i saw something that said
avocado tastes like clean penis and i've
been able to enjoy guac since for sure
guac anyone choosing salsa over
guacamole can immediately be placed in a
retirement home and cease all
communication
big guacamole guy but sauce can go with
more things shout out mexican cuisine
if sal is guac and we know that you are
he is going to use the argument of the
perfect guac is better than the average
salsa you're wrong grant townsend and
then he wrote but no restaurant can make
perfectly fresh guac every time yes they
can salsa has so many variations uh red
tomato mango pineapple salsa verde
didn't even get into it all right we
might not have a winning tweet here
let's we got to move on though
sorry nobody wrote anything funny they
were all serious comments let's see who
wins
yes
come on
horse [ __ ]
give me 11 000 votes
salsa wins it 59.6 to 40.4 percent
thank you so much
thank you so much
because
oh god thank you i needed that i thought
i was going to lose this one because i
think i'm losing coke sprite
but
i thought i was going to lose it
i thought i was going to come out one
and two today and i was going to win a
tootsie pop
are you feeling bold
at the coke sprite you want to do one
refresh
on the on the uh tootsie blow and just
see what happens
i'm going home
we should we should make a rule that if
something is below one percent
but
if it's below one percent
we should revisit it within five minutes
i i don't know about that rule we'll
think about that all right uh i say just
show us the results so this is the last
one to pull and in this short amount of
time is already up to sixteen thousand
show us the results of this one wait
wait i don't like reading the comments
does coke have its own slam dunk contest
that's what i thought
thank you zach all right
sprite tastes like the tears of former
child soldiers mixed with lemon pine
salt no way that can stack up to coke
i cur i personally find the color of
pepsi and coke to be suspect sure it's
brown i'm not bear gr
grills so i don't know grills we know
what piss tastes like but i'm assuming
that piss is sprite if you took the
sugar out
it should have been coke versus pepsi
real sorry
grunk
sprite and the free disney week got me
through chickenpox in the fourth grade
sprite
if you if you pick sprite please get in
the bin i like that that's very funny
the clarity of sprite leads me to
believe that it has no soul
sprite is a refreshing drink drinking a
coke tastes like a shot of cough syrup
and it leaves a gross film on your
throat i agree with you alicia
had a flavor called spread on fire i
wish their production line was
that's our lead as a child i preferred
sprite then my balls dropped and i
discovered the power of coke all right
that's your lead
sprite tastes like licking an old tube
tv no it doesn't yeah i don't disagree
all right all right the correct answer
is always diet coke and f itself
coke just hits different
and you know it sprite is the water of
soda
all right let's give it to the guy that
said his balls dropped
[Music]
congrats anthony feeney follow him at
a-n-t-h-o-n-y-f-i-n-n-i
all right folks
all right just give it to me
not too bad not too not too bad but
65.8 coke to 34.2 sprite i don't think
that's recoverable by sprite but i also
don't think it was like a an insane
route
oh my god i still love you babe i love
you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste bud